samedi la route je sais que tu as
peut-être un praticable mais hier
le l'air d'être annoncé
Michel Beaulieu est un producteur
laitier en colère cela fait plusieurs
jours qu'il n'a pas vu le camion qui
vient habituellement chercher son lait
dimanche il a appris qu'à cause de la
tempête le camion de passerait pas
résultat il a dû jeter 4300 litres de
lait
dans le trou là
ben on a travaillé pour rien
rien pour ça c'est
une perte puis il faut l'absorber puis
continuer monsieur Beaulieu chiffre la
perte financière à environ 4000 dollars
et il craint de ne pas être indemnisé il
dit n'avoir jamais vécu une telle
situation en 35 ans de carrière même
lors de la crise du verglas
j'ai jamais perdu un litre de lait il y
avait 4 pouces de glace dans le chemin
on a eu je pense une petite tempête
accompagnée de 98 puis ils ont décidé de
pas rembourser le lait par courriel la
PDG des producteurs laitiers de
l'Ontario nous a indiqué que l'absence
de certains transporteurs étaient
inévitables en raison des violentes
tempêtes hivernales à travers l'Ontario
elle ajoute que si les routes peuvent
sembler dégagées dans une zone elles
sont dangereuses dans d'autres Michel
Beaulieu lui estime que sa naugure rien
de bon pour le futur
comment vous voulez qu'on arrive
j'ai bien hâte de voir la prochaine
tempête qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui va
arriver nous avons contacté le
transporteur qui n'est pas venu chercher
le lait mais il ne veut faire aucun
commentaire le producteur laitier lui
exige toujours une explication ici Fiona
collian Radio-Canada à Sainte-Anne de
Prescott dans l'estompe